- [Male 1] How you do you
really experience something?
- By doing things.
Look, everybody is trying to mitigate risk
and hedge against vulnerabilities.
I run into them.
- Let me just stop so I can do another one
- I run right the fuck into them.
- Just in case.
(inspirational music)
7:06 AM, Singapore, there's
a morning show right?
- Yep.
- Morning show action here in Asia.
Long trip huh?
- Long trip.
- You get some sleep?
- A little bit.
- Yeah, I got a little bit too, not a lot.
Anyway, just riding along.
You know, being 12 hours ahead kinda sucks
because you wake up to 146 emails of fire.
So, just trying to catch up
and drink out of the fire hose.
It's like fire coming out
of the fire hose, not water.
That I could deal with.
- [Interviewer] What
does hustle mean to you?
Why is it important?
- For me, it's important
because I don't think
any of us in this room or
anybody reading this article
can physically change how smart they are.
I don't think we can make ourselves
more clever or more strategic,
but I do think that hard work is the most
controllable aspect of
entrepreneurship and business
that anybody can deploy,
and I find that fascinating.
Right, and I'm just willing to work
until you guys feel satisfied.
I'm not worried about the
margin, you know what I mean?
Then, I would add one last thing.
I would argue, I'd rather
somebody continue to persevere
around something they love doing.
Like, if you love making ice cream sundaes
and you want to become
the number one expert
of ice cream sundaes with the hope of
opening ice cream sundae stores,
I weirdly would rather you
not all the way make it,
kind of live paycheck to paycheck,
but be so happy than go and do law,
be miserable and make a
little bit more money that
allows you to take a
vacation or have a fancy car.
So, it's a complex question.
Some can argue to me
that they are so insecure
that they need a Rolex and a BMW
and that's what scratches
the itch for them.
I'm okay with that.
To me, you making $87,000 a
year writing about esports
is more attractive than making
$210,000 as a consultant
in the way that I view life.
It's the most controllable
and I try to give advice
that is actually practical,
not makes me look cool.
So, that's why I love hustle.
I'm an unbelievable buyer of the modern
consumption patterns of the consumer
because I'm unemotional.
While many in this room
and many watching at home
are just trying to figure out what to do
in this environment, we
are now in the pre-dawn
of our attention being shifted to audio.
Whether in podcast form or very soon,
Alexa, Google, Apple
devices that become the
AI, ML voice interactions of our day.
Whatever obviously Tencent and Alibaba
do it in the Asian markets.
This is going to be the next frontier
of attention arbitrage.
So, I highly recommend that
you get far more disciplined
in your understanding on where your actual
customer's attention is
and not be lazy and say,
"Well my customer is older.
Well my customer is richer."
They're not on these platforms.
In that naivety will become great
detriment to your ambitions.
The nimbleness in my lack of romance
of what's working for me today
and the underlining work
ethic and humility that
I deploy against the next consumer trend.
I lack the audacity
that most of the people
in this room have about
how they want it to be
versus how it actually is.
I trade on that currency.
It's practical to take high risk between
20 and 30 now with the way
the internet is structured.
It is smarter to take high
risk entrepreneurial ventures
between 20 and 30 now than
to go into a corporation.
The main reason 20-30 year olds
still go into a corporation
is because of the scratch that they have.
The itch that they have to
scratch to appease their parents.
And that over indexes in Asia.
But, it's not practical.
Do you know how young you are at 30?
Do you know how much
opportunity there actually is?
Do you know how much you
can do if you're not willing
to live fancy and live humbly?
It's unbelievable.
Companies are in big trouble because
the feeding system of universities,
in America they're in
deep trouble because...
I don't know the Singapore market,
but in America there's an incredible heist
and fraud going on.
It's called debt to go to University.
There's nobody now at...
I get a thousand emails
a week, Dms on instagram
from 16-year olds that are like,
"I'm a straight A student,
my parents want me to go to college,
I want to be an entrepreneur."
Of course, because it's cool
and most people can't be, so I get it.
But, follow along.
My parents are poor,
and they want me to go
to this university to make them feel good.
The amount of things that
people in this room have done
because of the insecurities of
their parents is stunning to me.
It's sad.
And, in America, it's compounded because
kids are taking on $250,000 in debt
with high interest rates and aren't
getting anything when they come out.
That won't last.
So, we're in...
Listen, how are you not
smart enough to realize
there's something called the internet?
It's finally hit some level of maturity
because now it's about 25,
20 years old consumer facing.
Do we not realize how big of a...
It's the single biggest thing
that has happened to the human race.
It's arbitraged out the physical world.
This is so much bigger than
I think we're quantifying.
I talk about the communication
and marketing aspects,
but everything you see around block chain,
and Trump, and Brexit, and China.
This is the preview.
We haven't even started.
Everything is up for grabs.
- It's all good. Let's do it.
- I love the show. Hello.
So, basically everyone here right now,
they're from the startup space.
Mostly FenCheck.
- Okay.
- Then, they've already
come with all their
questions prepared, so
just go your own style.
- Right into Q & A?
- Yeah, right into Q & A.
- I love it.
Did you always dream to be on DailyVee?
- Never, I didn't know
this was gonna happen.
- Now it happened.
- This is like a miracle for me.
- This is a huge miracle.
- [Audience Member] I
used to always think that
I'm an entrepreneur, but
you make me realize that
I am not entrepreneur but I am
someone who has entrepreneur tendencies.
- Yes.
- [Audience Member] So, I think
that's a big thing for me.
So, that comes to my question that.
I have big ambition, I think education
has the power to change lives.
For me, my childhood dream
to be a business owner
by age 40, I already accomplished it.
Right now, communicating what's next.
It's just about legacy over currency.
For me, I want to build a foundation,
build skills to give back to society.
One thing that I have is
that you talk about ambition
and the willingness, the hustle.
I have the ambition, but
the willingness, the hustle
for the ambition is lacking.
- Why?
- [Audience Member] I ask that
question to myself as well.
- What's the real answer?
- [Audience Member] I'll
say that it's my parents
in a small step, but I
think that's also bullshit.
I think the biggest thing is myself.
I wonder if maybe I'm scared
of success or failure.
Even though I'm comfortable, but then
I'm not sure whether I can do it really.
But at the same time, I
feel like I can do it.
- I think the biggest
thing that you have to...
I think both your answers are right.
I think once you get into a place where
your failures are just yours,
they get a lot less scary.
You answered the right thing.
Whether it's your parents or
somebody else in your life.
The biggest reason
people don't take risks,
is they worry about
other people's opinions.
I wish you guys could feel what I feel
in my heart and in my soul.
I do not care about a single person's
point of view about me.
While equally caring about
what you think about me.
It's a very interesting contradiction.
It's a subtlety, but
saying both your parents
and yourself, it's...
When I hear I'm scared to fail,
but I feel like I can do it,
you're just worrying about outside forces.
It's no different than the way,
like I love if my professor
is a 40, 50, 60 year old
when I was 25 would have shit on me
because I was excited about
sticking it to them later.
If I didn't, here's a big one.
I don't talk about this as much.
When I fail, I'm excited because it meant
that I deserved to fail.
I love the game so much
even at my own expense.
I can't be pumped about
the fruits of victory
without equally respecting
the agony of the defeat.
I'm excited when I fail.
I'm like, "Okay, tough guy."
The sneaker, this is interesting to me.
Why did I do this deal?
It was win-win.
If it works, I get to run
around with the legacy
of being the first entrepreneur
with a signature sneaker
and then it's kinda cool.
Like, in 20 years entrepreneurs
are just like athletes
and musicians and have sneakers.
I can sit here in 20 years and be like,
"You know, the way I thought
about the first sneaker,"
You know, it's cool.
It's a legacy play of
being strategically right.
But if I fail, it's ammo for
my friends to make fun of me.
Like, "Remember when you
thought you were so cool tough guy?"
It's funny.
But, I have to have
that humility as much as
I have that confidence to
be able to do my thing.
You have to be okay with losing.
I have a different question for you.
Which is, I agree with
you that education has
the chance to change the world
because it's already happened.
Education changed the world.
My bigger question is,
I just want to make sure
that you're not overly
romantic of the format
of the delivery of the education.
So, I'm fascinated by everybody right now
in our current state being in technology.
Let me explain.
The fact that we in society
put a hand written note
on a pedestal as this
is some great gesture
versus when we text people.
It's fascinating to me
because we've put the medium
on a pedestal not the action.
So, you're telling me
if I write an incredible
six sentence empathetic
love letter to my mom
of my admiration of her in text form,
that for some reason is less powerful than
a hand-written note for that same delivery
just because we're anti-technology,
because we fear change?
I laugh at that.
That's how I think about education.
I do not believe in a lot
of ways that education
is being dispersed because it is in the
selfish financial
interest of the disperser.
So, one weird insight could be that
that's your unlock,
that you believe in it,
but subconsciously you know
that the format is bullshit.
- [Audience Member] Thank You.
- You're welcome.
Right?
- Yeah, I appreciate that.
- Understand, yeah. Thank you.
How are you?
- Just wanted to thank
you for the feedback.
- Thank you, thank you.
Our J & J meeting right now?
Are we late?
I have a client that we have to go.
Guys, I'm so sorry, I
have a client meeting.
(crowd chatter)
- Thank you man, thank you for coming.
- Very interesting.
- Thank you for coming.
That's awesome man.
- But I don't know how to do it right now
because I'm still studying and I'm like
trying to intern and trying to learn
entrepreneurship a little bit.
Trying to be more explore about this.
- Something around
something as unique as that,
it's gonna be about patience because
people aren't gonna see it.
It's gonna take time.
- Definitely.
- You know what I mean?
- To me, you've been enforcing it.
- Content, content, content,
patience, patience, patience.
Execution.
- Just freakin start.
- Good?
- Alright, thank you so much Gary.
- You're welcome brother.
- See you in Indonesia.
- See you soon.
(calming music)
- Good, we had a good
meeting with a client.
Or, a potential client.
A client from a macro
level, big corporate client
that has an office here.
Kind of talked about our ambitions
and the southeast Asian market.
So, this is an awfully productive trip.
I also get awfully ambitious
when I'm in new territory.
I just want to transcribe
all of my content
into every language in the world.
I'm also thinking it's
12:57 and we've done
more than a full days worth
of work for most people.
We have another 14 hours to go.
- [Cameraman] Wanna get a little touch tap
right there, that was odd.
That was weird.
- I liked it, let's do it again.
- [Cameraman] Like E.T.
- Phone home baby. Phone home DRock.
- I want to say thanks.
- I appreciate it buddy.
- So, hopefully.
- Thank you so much.
- Something comes out of this trip.
- It's already been awesome man.
I'm not worried about the results.
I'm worried about the setup, you know.
Tomorrow, every single person can get
different product in the news feed.
Go into Facebook Search,
type in soccer and football,
like 400 pictures and videos
from soccer and watch
your news feed change.
Tomorrow, type in Chiang Kai-shek
and like everything and
watch your news feed change.
Tomorrow type in Beyonce.
Tomorrow type in pineapple
Tomorrow type in red watches,
and watch your news feed change.
Facebook's not manipulating you.
You're manipulating Facebook.
It's time to take ownership.
- You've also come to be known
as a serial entrepreneur.
You have invested in
a number of start ups.
So, how do you know if an idea works?
- You don't.
You don't. You make an intuitive call
on the jockey and the horse.
You gotta like the person,
you gotta like the idea.
Some things work out, some don't.
Venmo, I love the idea,
I love the operator.
They were good enough to
get it to a certain point,
but then they had to sell
because they couldn't
take it to the next level.
Now it's one of the most
valuable companies in the world,
but I didn't make any money.
- For you it's a gut feel?
- For everybody it's a gut feel.
Let me explain by that.
A lot of VCs invest on data
that is projected data.
That's called gut feel.
They wanna be fancy and
be in those tall buildings
and wear a suit and say
that they make decisions on
analytics, but if you're
making a decision on pure math,
you should be right 100% of the time.
So, what are these VCs guessing on?
Guessing, gut.
- Order over here.
- You got it, no problem.
- Thank you Mr. Gary.
- You're welcome.
- Come take a picture with me, selfie.
- Let's do it.
Awesome. So nice to meet you.
- Pleasure.
- Thank you.
Here's why I'm really
really good at what I do.
90% of the media I consume in my life
is reading people's comments
on content that I put out.
I basically spend my
life on consumer behavior
and reaction to content.
Talk to you soon.
- I'll wait.
- Okay, great. Yeah, no problem.
That was a lot of fun.
I like those kind of talks.
The internation squad,
I wanna give you guys
a huge shout out, big love.
I appreciate it, I'm flattered by it.
I don't really know what else to say.
What else we wanna tell 'em?
- Just keep hustling, keep
working hard, keep grinding.
Keep listening to everything
that Gary has to say.
- Don't listen to what
I say, watch what I do.
That's the key.
Anyway, sending my love.
Thank you guys in the
community for all of it.
See ya.
(inspirational music)
- Thank you sir.
- Of course, come on in.
- I have a couple of questions for you.
- Of course.
Hello, hello, hi.
Nice to meet you, Gary.
Hi, nice to meet you. How are you?
- I didn't get your name sorry.
- Gary.
(chattering)
Hello.
- Hi I'm Pearcy, Gary.
How are you?
- Hi, Gary?
- What an influencer, what you guys offer
is a total different context and a
total different affiliation for a brand.
So, do I think brands
should spend on Instagram?
I do.
Do I think they should
also spend on KOLs, I do.
Because the people that
follow her or him or her
have an affinity for that person.
I mean, there's always been
a reason why sponsorship
and endorsement and people
affiliation always works.
So, I don't think it's an either/or.
I think it's a both.
You also have to
understand that Facebook is
six months away from
making sure they make a
20% vig on everything everybody does,
which will then allow them to be very
comfortable with you making money
as long as they're making their tax.
I think what KOLs have to do is be more
thoughtful about how they promote.
It blows my mind that
people that are in position
to make millions of dollars
a year are willing to take
$40,000 from a detox tea
and give that all away.
- But at the same time,
you should just test right?
- I test everything.
First of all, and I think
you've all seen this,
creative is the variable of success.
You know, the better
you get at this craft,
at growth hacking, at
growing, best practices.
We all have done stuff
with best practices;
hashtags, titles on youtube,
first three seconds.
We've all done stuff and every day
over the years that you've been doing it,
whether a year or ten years,
you do something that you
didn't expect to happen
because the creative was the variable.
The creative is gray, not black and white.
That's why testing is everything.
I basically think I'm in
full testing mode always.
I accept nothing.
I'm constantly innovating
everything I'm doing.
Don't forget, we're spending,
the media are spending
300 million dollars a
year on Facebook ads.
I'm look at real data, not just my own.
And, it's the creative, and
best practices, and continuity.
Then, it's just the things
that come native to you.
Like, collaborations, so important.
So many of you right now
should take a picture
with each other and post
across, like such a benefit.
It's just such light-weight ROI.
So, there's a lot, it's a heavy matrix.
And then, once you get into that place
where you're selling stuff.
How much value you have to give
in return to convert
properly when you ask.
There's all these variables.
I wrote a book called "Jab,
Jab, Jab, Right Hook".
It was about give, give,
give, and then ask.
That cadence of how much you're giving
versus you're asking in return is probably
the most philosophical importance of where
you'll probably go going forward.
When you become a personal brand,
when you mis-balance giving
versus asking, you are finished.
You're on the start of the process
of going in the other direction.
Because everybody's about
to be a personal brand.
- [Member Of Meeting]
Give before you take.
- Give as much as you can.
You know what my thesis is?
Guilt them into buying
because you give them so much.
I'm in full guilt mode.
I'm in full guilt strategy.
(laughing)
- Gary, you always talk about getting
out of your comfort zone,
why it's so important.
- Yes, uh oh.
- We're in Singapore, so I wanna see if
we can get you out of yours.
Have you heard of durian?
- Oh my god, I have
been dying to try this.
- Really?
- Yeah, so you see this in
all the extreme food stuff.
I am so curious what's about.
Guys, this is a big deal for me actually.
- First and foremost,
the smell, good, bad?
What do you think?
- This is it?
- You know this is banned on the subway
- Oh, god this is good and bad.
It's super interesting.
- It's literally banned
because it's so strong.
So, we brought you some durian.
- Do you eat durian?
- I've never had it myself, so.
I've been afraid.
I've lived here a year and
a half and I've been afraid.
- Okay.
- Give it another smell.
- Man, it's real.
- Really?
- Yeah, but it's cool.
Alright, so what are we doing?
How much do you eat?
(laughing)
- You gotta go for more than that.
- I'm gonna be good with it.
- I think this is how much
you're supposed to eat.
- You eat that. You got it.
- Alright, then you.
- It's good.
(laughing)
You weren't ready for it?
- I really wasn't.
- I kind of like it, but I was
obviously cautious with the volume.
I'm kind of okay with it.
- You gotta plunge Gary, you gotta plunge.
- I mean, it's some weird stuff man.
- Yeah, you did it man, congratulations.
- I'm good with it, but it smells.
It's wild stuff.
Are you pumped you at least now tried?
- Yeah, I'm pumped.
- Are you devastated
that you were defeated
and I was unbelievably remarkable with it?
- It's not a competition.
Who said it was a competition?
- My friend, everything is a competition.
- Alright, on that note congratulations.
- Thank you man, good to see you again.
- Great to catch up
with you, and well done.
- Bye guys.
(sad music)
♫ I hope you go
♫ I hope I see you
♫ Golden shores with lights
more radiant than the sun
♫ You say you won't
♫ You won't believe...
- If you go to my website right now,
it says that I day trade attention.
That's what I do, the end.
It's day trading attention.
It's so much more real
than people realize.
Wish, are you guys familiar
with Wish the shopping app?
Wish has gone from zero
to anywhere between
5-7 billion dollars on transactional sales
on their platform on
100% Facebook arbitrage.
- [Dinner Member] But
you can also quickly..
- They've already moved.
They know it's starting to mature
and if you look at what they're doing,
there's a logo on the Lakers jersey.
If you watched the
McGregor/Mayweather fight,
they did brand.
Now they're doing above,
now they're doing branding.
They did sales conversion.
Now they're moving to branding
as it's maturing, but it's
still grossly under-priced.
KOLs, I would tell you
KOLs and influencers is
the great misunderstood market place
right now for any business including
very boring B to B sass businesses.
It's just attention that's under-priced.
- [Dinner Member] Content based.
- Always, it's the variable of success.
Once you figure out where the
attention is under-priced.
Google was great for analytical people
because it was blue letters,
and it was intent based.
Facebook is television and so
you have to be dramatically
more creative to arbitrage Facebook,
which is why a lot of analytical
people have struggled.
And, then all the big brands.
I always point to you, because Unilever.
I apologize, but this is who I work with.
All the big brands, they're in television.
All the quant-based
marketers are struggling
with the creative variable,
and you have this dichotomy.
That's why Facebook is still so vibrant
for under-priced opportunity.
- [Dinner Member] Because
there's the other issue of
ephemeral versus very permanent
entrance attention span
and actually there's
certain digital properties
that are grabbing the
permanent attention span space,
but there's a lot on the ephemeral side.
There's very different business
models associated with that.
- Yeah, and I think people are
too hypercritical ephemeral
because ephemeral is like how
the world actually worked.
I agree.
- [Dinner Member] The way you
scan it is different though.
- 100%, but you know what's ironic?
Obviously Snapchat had it's
real moment with ephemeral.
That's far more similar to the way
everything has been done prior.
Television's ephemeral.
Magazine's ephemeral.
Direct mail's ephemeral.
- Just slower.
- It's ephemeral.
Tonight's ephemeral, like 100%.
♫ It's gonna go
♫ In the blink of an eye
♫ And I just wanna know
♫ You'll be there by my side
♫ And it can feel so cold
♫ But I'm holding onto hope
♫ That one day your
heart will make it home
♫ It's gonna go
♫ In the blink of an eye
♫ And I just wanna know
♫ You'll be there
(cheering)
♫ And it can feel so cold
♫ But I'm holding on
- I just wanna thank everybody
for coming out tonight.
I'm sure there's a lot of
other things you could be doing
and I'm very flattered.
I'm glad I got to say hello
to everybody real quick.
I'm looking forward to...
Jesus, that's a big beer.
(laughing)
I'm excited to talk to a bunch of you.
I've had an incredible two full days,
very full days, thank you Rysa
for packing my schedule
for 18 fuckin hours a day.
DRock and I are going to be
very happy to leave in an hour
so we can finally get to
the airport and go to sleep.
I've really enjoyed it.
Maybe you've heard, we have some serious
ambitions of opening an office here.
So, I have a funny feeling,
I'll be seeing you guys around.
Thank you so much for the hospitality.
I think the entrepreneurial spirit,
the class, the grit,
it' been very fruitful.
I've really enjoyed it.
I'm really looking forward to saying hello
and getting to know some
of you guys tonight.
If not fully tonight, I'm
sure hopefully in the future.
So, I wish you guys
nothing but good health
and all good stuff, and I
hope you have a nice night.
Thanks for coming out.
The only mentor I've ever
had is you guys; the market.
The market is my mentor.
The market is my religion.
The consumer has been my
guide from a little kid.
Lemonade, like it's crazy.
Now that I've learned...
You know how you're starting
to get even in your 20's,
you're starting to
understand yourself better.
When I think back to what I did as a kid,
how consumer centric.
Baseball card shows, sports memorabilia.
I would do something, now
I'm like, "Oh my god."
Everybody would set up their table.
Before the mall or the
convention center would open,
you set up your table, your booth.
I didn't.
I would never set up.
I would walk the entire floor; context.
Who's pricing what?
What do people have on their tables?
Is it football cards,
is it baseball cards?
Is there a certain player that's hot?
Then, I would wait for the first hour and
watch what people did at those tables.
Then I would go set up.
It's funny, I talk so much.
Sit down, talk.
But I'm listening a lot.
So, my mentor is the game; the market.
Thank you so much, thank you.
We're going to my hotel,
right to get bags?
- [Cameraman] Yeah.
- Hey guys, it's 11:06.
DRock, I have no idea how you're planning
on editing this episode,
but you better fuckin show
the fact that I've been fucking talking
and taking questions and answers for
the last fucking 14 straight hours.
I will punch you in the
nose if you don't show it.
This was a real fucking grinder Singapore.
♫ One day your heart
♫ Will make it home
- Alright guys, it's your
favorite moment of every vlog.
This time I really need it.
Do you know about the greatest
action hero of all time?
- I have no idea.
- You're looking at one of
the great transformations
when I go from a mere mortal man
to the great superhero of our generation.
This is when I turn into airport Gary.
I have music, there's
music playing right now.
Oh yeah, there's music.
Now I am rejuvenated and unstoppable.
- [Woman] That's amazing.
(applause)